the broadcast is now starting all
attendees are in listen only mode hey
good afternoon everybody uh welcome to
today's presentation my name is michael
baltos and i'm the owner and trader at
orderflows.com
and today you're in for a special treat
i'll be talking about advanced order
flow techniques so that you can trade
like a pro you know um i've got over 20
years of professional training
experience on the back end i work for
major trading firms and banks and today
i'm going to be teaching and talking
about you know some of the things that
i've learned over the years that you can
apply to your own uh to your own trading
to become more successful
at it so in today's training
you're going to discover how to read
order flow basically understanding the
price action and volume dynamics at work
you know most traders are familiar with
price action
it's you know it's a term that gets
thrown around a lot and there are some
drawbacks to trading strictly on price
action but i want to show you how you
could add volume to your analysis to
make you know better trading decisions
i'm going to also show you some advanced
techniques for trading with order flow
now when i talk about order flow it's
really the combination of volume and
price action
and lastly i'm going to show you how you
can use order flow analysis to your
advantage in today's market conditions
you know nowadays
you know the market is uh
it's pretty volatile you know there's no
other way to sugarcoat it and
you know we've seen days where it looks
like it's a it's a huge down day and the
market rallies to close that unchanged
or even positive and order flow is going
to help you take advantage of those
situations now
if you're sort of new to order flow you
know or you want to you know learn
the basics of order flow
easily and quickly you know i wrote a
book a few years ago
it's called trading order flow and if
you stick around to the end i'm gonna
show you how you get a copy of that
it's 150 page book you know i've spent
close to two years writing it
and
basically it talks about you know sort
of my background because i have an
institutional trading background and
it's going to show you how you can use
order flow to determine what the
institutions are doing you know it's
going to talk about how not all prices
are the same
how to limit your risk on a trade how to
determine things like price rejection
understanding value in the market and
much much more
so you're going to get a download link
to that at the end of today's
presentation
so you know just briefly on who i am
because you know sometimes you know
people come to one of my presentations
you're not familiar with who i am and
you know my background and
i hate to say why you should listen to
me but
you know people
there's a lot of people out there online
that
put themselves out as
trading gurus so to speak now i'm not
saying i'm a guru or anything but i just
want you to know my background uh so you
can understand that what i'm teaching is
things that i've learned on a
professional level trading at
you know major firms i started on the
cme floor as a runner with dean witter
and you know i worked my way up through
the
the hierarchy so you will
and you know eventually i left the
trading floor the cme floor to
join the overnight trading desk at dean
witter when the electronic trading
started taking off you know that was
back in the early 90s or sorry mid 90s
when globex
was just starting to take off you know
the overnight
exchanges from
cme
cbot nymex access and after doing that
for several years i left i joined the
big commodity english commodity trading
firm edf man
you know it's been around since the
1700s you know they've got their start
trading sugar but they literally trade
every commodity you can imagine
after two years that man i joined
commerce bank the big german bank
in chicago i was their urex trader i
traded buns bobbles shots
uh dax
euro stocks
and you know i trade that against the
u.s products
now
after september 11th i took about six
months off traveled around
sort of you know
look for the meaning in life if you will
and
after that you know i said it was time
for me i'm ready to come back to
the finance industry and i joined
cargill cargill is a big the biggest
in u.s private trading company
um you know they account for about 30 of
grain exports 25 of meat exports but
again like edf man they trade every
commodity imaginable and
after about three years in chicago they
asked me to go out to singapore to set
up a trading desk when the exchange was
closing down um to go fully electronic
right the open outcry in singapore was
ending and they needed a trading desk
set up so they sent me out to singapore
i spent a year there
before joining jp morgan in singapore
where i was vice president of future
streams so my background is futures it's
all i did for
um you know over 20 years
at very high levels
but
i realized there was more to life than
just you know working in a company i got
to the point where i was spending more
time on the trading desk than i was at
home
and that's not how i wanted to live my
life and so in 2013 i left jp morgan
and just started trading for myself i
i've already learned how to trade i
spent 20 or 20 years trading um you know
for banks for
commodity trading firms so i said you
know i could do this on my own and
that's what i did i struck out to
trade as an independent trader
the software that was available right
when you're an independent trader
you know back in
it's very limited on the amount of
software that's out there now you know
software's exploding you know there's a
lot of new software's out there
but you know it was like tradestation
ninjatrader
um
multicharts you know just you know a
handful and the order flow software that
was available was was very basic right
it was just the normal footprint chart
and i sat down with a programmer who
understood order flow a bit and i said
you know what there's things i look for
in the order flow let's put that into
the software so that it will make my
trading easier and as a result we came
up with what's called the order flows
trader now originally
it was created just for my own trading
right it wasn't something i didn't want
to get in the software business you know
i just
been spending all this time writing my
book and i realized you know what
computers are there to make our life
easier
let's take this analysis and put it into
a software okay so that will highlight
to on a chart for a trader you know
where
market weakness was or price rejection
was occurring and so on and
that's how i developed the software and
again it was originally from my own use
but then other traders i was sharing my
charts with you know like hey what's
that software and you know eventually
other people like hey i'll pay you for
that and that's how the order flows um
trader software business started now you
know so the reason why i talked about
that is because the charts you're going
to see in today's presentation are
generated using my software now
before we begin you know just the brief
disclaimer trading does involve risk
we're all adults you know you shouldn't
be trading with money you can't afford
to lose
all right so
first thing i'll talk about is
understanding the price action
and volume dynamics at work right it's
not
the markets don't necessarily trade in a
vacuum in the sense that you know price
moves up price moves down and that's it
you know all you have to do is look at
price really what you want to do is you
want to look at how it traded when it
traded up or how it traded when it
traded down right if there's any clues
into
you know what market participants are
doing in the market
and price action and volume are the two
most important dynamics that work in the
market so when you understand how these
factors interact
you're going to gain insight into market
trends and make more informed trading
decisions so first what is price action
well it's the movement of prices on a
chart
basically that's it right we've all seen
charts but you know we're going to look
at price action for clues as to whether
buyers or sellers in control of the
market you know to sort of help predict
if you will future price movements but
the problem is when you look at
a chart right this is your normal
candlestick chart
people will say well price action right
i'm a price action trader well there's
negative price action here there's
negative price action here
negative price action here but the
market still keeps going up right and
what do i mean by negative price action
we've seen lower highs lower lows as the
market
starting to come down stalls out lower
highs lower lows
lower highs lower low so price action
you know while in theory
you know is useful you really need to
wrap it around something else and that
is
volume
now volume
is really the measure of how much
trading activity is taking place right
now when most traders look at volume
they tend to gravitate towards total
volume right the total volume for the
bar the total volume for the day but to
be honest it's kind of pointless to try
to analyze
total volume for the day when you're
trading
millions of contracts a day you know
mini nasdaq right trades
two million contracts a day you know and
it's average it's probably around 2.2
million contracts a day
now you're trying to
if you're looking at on a daily basis
well this day it traded um 2.1 this
other day traded 2.4 you know you're
you're trying to make something out of
nothing right it's just sometimes it
deals with the volatility in the market
but as a trader you can actually break
it down
to a very micro level
you can look at the volume traded on the
bid and the volume traded on the offer
and
where does volume
come from in a sense i mean it comes
from obviously the trading that you see
right on the trading dome right what's
being traded on the bid what's being
traded on the offer but every trade that
you see happen shows up in the time and
sales chart
now
the problem with the time and sales
chart is it moves too fast to
really make any
trading decision from and you know i see
a lot of people you know they run
trading rooms or you know they run
streams and they'll have a time and
sales up there but to be honest are they
even looking at it you know
nowadays
you can't it just moves too fast you
know in the old days and i'm talking
about you know the the 90s
yeah you could look at time and sales
because
back in the 90s
even a little bit into the early 2000s
you didn't have you know high frequency
trading
you had people just banging away on on a
computer even in those old days you know
people
when e-minis first started trading and
you could get a membership to trade
e-minis and you could look into the big
s p pit the guys had a little uh like a
nintendo controller you know buy and
sell buy and sell like that really quick
that was like
the beginning of sort of this high
frequency um trading that was going on
but to be honest you know every lot of
things that you're seeing go through is
small sizes of one and two lots the
average trade
in the e-minis is is just like 1.3
contracts so it's telling you most of
the volume that goes through is like
one two one one one two you know
sometimes you're going to get a 25 lot
of 50 lot like that but the majority of
the contracts it's going through is one
and if you obviously if you have a time
and sales going up and you're just
looking at
a lot of ones
okay that means nothing you know
sometimes it here's a nine lot that went
through
you know that's nothing
but when you're looking at the
time and sales right you can see
you know people
probably never realize you know why it's
green and why it's you know this reddish
colors
when there's a certain activity training
you know if someone lifts the bid
buys the offer
right that's the aggressive buying if
someone sells into the bid
that's aggressive selling right and it's
going to show up in different colors
so like i believe the um aggressive
selling is going to be this orange the
aggressive bind is going to be the green
right so you want to know that you want
then you can start seeing well you know
because we know there's always two-sided
trades right there's always a bid and
offers trading on the bid in the offer
but you can start to see when there's
more aggressive buying or aggressive
selling in a direction
and all this information that you see
moves so fast on a time and sales you
can actually put it into a chart into a
footprint chart
then you can see price action and volume
together and you get a better sense of
what's happening in the market
right now i know that
you know at the high of the day up here
i know that 71 contracts traded at this
high price uh
41.26 but i know that all the volume
traded on the offer 71 contracts i know
that when it was one tick below the high
it was 117 traded on the bid 132 on the
offer
now
most of the volume that you see go
through
isn't important for your analysis
okay and you know the thing with
looking at order flow is a lot of times
traders get scared of you know they see
numbers and they immediately get scared
thinking oh my gosh you know i got to
interpret all this stuff no you don't
what you're looking for
are the
the little nuances in the market right
where aggressive buying is happening you
know it's not just one thing to see that
there was aggressive selling in a bar or
aggressive buying but you want to know
where it's happening in relation to
you know say the previous bar or the
previous swing high etc
you know as opposed to just saying oh
there's a buying and balance i should
buy
so
when you start putting volume and price
action together then you start to find
out more about the market such as where
is value forming right and you know
value is a concept i'm going to talk
about in depth a little bit uh further
in today's training
but
there are ways to highlight the volume
or sorry the value
on the footprint chart so you can see
areas where
value is moving higher here
and value
is overlapping right areas where volume
or sorry value is overlapping is
generally going to be your sideways
activity in the market as you can see
here right i'm able to draw
out the value area for a bar right now
most people are familiar with value
areas right if you're familiar with
volume profile
or market profile you understand what
the value area is and you know traders
of volume profile market profile will
look at daily profiles
and look for areas of value developing
you know over time right value develops
over time whereas price trades
at a particular point in time
and when you start to see value
overlapping whether it's on a bar by you
know on a minute by minute basis this is
that they're actually a 30 second chart
or a 15 minute chart or daily chart
right if this was one day and see the
values here the next day it came in
value is overlapping next day it's
overlapping
i know that we're going to be range
trading we're going to be trading
sideways it's when value starts to move
higher or lower as you see down here
that trends start to happen and one of
the clearest signs of a market
that's starting to trend
is a break in value
right you have this area where you got
one two three four five six seven bars
where value is overlapping it's
basically trading sideways right we can
see that right if you're just looking at
the the normal chart you can see you
know it's a sideways activity but now
we're starting to see value gap right
this bar's value is much higher than the
value area low of this bar is higher
than the value error high of the
previous bar so it's a gap in value
and usually when you see these gaps in
value that's when trends start to happen
right and we moved up we hit a swing
high
now we see a gap in value here right
before he starts selling off
a couple bars overlapping say you're not
convinced that you know the market is
turned up here you got another gap in
value right here and the market keeps
selling off so you know that's when you
start putting price action and volume
together you get you start to see more
in the markets
you know another
great way to use um
value right the combination of price
action and volume is to see where
acceptance is in the market or rejection
is in the market
and
you know this is a great bar right here
it's obvious i know candlestick people
say well that's a bullish candle i'll
show you a bearish candle but what you
have here right the bar opened on it's
low traded all the way up you put in
this big massive
value area up in here you traded a lot
of volume up here but we close below
that what do you think the market is
telling you when you know
there's a lot of volume transacting
you know at a price or several price
levels you know traders have sort of
found that sweet spot where buyers and
sellers are you know more or less evenly
mixed
but now you got a lot of volume so
they're they found a
fair price that everyone wants to
transact and they're transacting up here
okay
buyers and sellers you know they traded
3 000 contracts in this one bar whereas
the previous bars it's like 700 900 you
know 800 700 but
it got to this level where both buyers
and sellers were both attracted to this
market sellers are attracted to this
high level because they want to sell at
these nice high prices buyers are
thinking this market's going higher
eventually
one side won the other lost
we're starting to reject these prices
you can see the bar closed below the
value so we opened up form this high
upper value area we close below it
and we start trading down
right so there's no acceptance up here
there was acceptance early as this bar
was forming but traders quickly rejected
these higher prices the buyers rejected
these higher prices realized they're not
going to be able to take this market
higher because there was sellers up in
here
passive sellers people that had supply
to sell
so they rejected these higher prices and
the market came right back down right
came right back down to where it was
just you know before it moved up to
those prices and then we more or less
trade sideways you know
on the rest of that chart
now again you know as i was just talking
about a little bit earlier when you know
where value is you can see when the
market is moving out of balance
and imbalance is forming okay so here
right you've got sort of these you know
one two three bars with balance value
areas overlapped right point of control
same level
and then it gaps right the value gaps
right the value area low of this bar is
much higher than the value area high of
you know these previous bars
obviously we're closing up
but now you're starting to see things
like buying and balances in the bar you
got that's the blue numbers in the bar
one two you got like eight in here
okay so you have values gapping higher
we're staying more or less you know
right at the value area now we did close
outside of the value area by one tick
okay but restore sort of in the midpoint
of the bar
then you wait for the next bar you know
wait to see what's going to happen is
this market just going to sell off and
keep selling off come back down no it's
holding
value area is overlapping
okay but again it's an inside bar so
it's not really doing much of anything
you wait for the next bar right you
still got to read the order flow what's
happening you put it in context with
what just happened
previous bar
so this third bar opens up
you got
several binding balances got three
binary balances in there we close above
the valuary high of the previous bar
okay
value is obviously not migrating lower
because the value area low is still
equal to the previous bars value area
low but we're closing obviously higher
than the previous bars value area
now is the point now now as a trader you
have to make a decision is this market
going higher or is this market going
lower
well if you're looking at what value is
doing yeah it looks like the market is
picking up
steam right value is starting to go
higher because value area highs
are going higher obviously you got
buying imbalances
there's absolutely no reason to be
looking to get short you know the only
trade
is to the upside
then you start to get up here and you
should just circle sideways right it
looks like it's going to reverse here
you got a little gap
down in value but then value starts
migrating higher then boom another gap
in here
so
yeah you start to think it's
your view now is bearish
and what happens it doesn't really go
anywhere it just goes sideways goes
inside inside inside bar you know three
bar you know values starting to overlap
when you start to see value overlap what
you're going to be looking for then is
the break in value
you saw one here but
it didn't continue and then just started
overlapping again in here and you know
that's the end of the chart but really
what you're looking for these areas
where you have value that's overlapping
and then the break the gap right here
for that move up
now order flow provides a trader with
very robust information you just have to
know how to use it right the information
is there it's available on the time and
sales
but not everybody
has a way of formatting it you know a
lot of people they don't use a footprint
chart right everyone always talks about
you have to have an edge
in trading
and using all this information that's
out there
and putting it into a format that's easy
to read a footprint chart is going to
give many traders that edge that they're
looking for
so the beauty of orderful analysis with
the footprint chart is not having to
analyze each tick the way you would with
say a dome or trying to look at time and
sales
or if you're looking at the dome right
you see where the bids and offers are
going in and getting pulled
but dome doesn't necessarily show you
what's trading right you have to look at
the time and sales to see what's trading
now another way that traders like to
look at the market nowadays is by using
a heat map right they're looking for
areas of resting liquidity
but
the problem with resting liquidity is
people sort of fall into this
false sense of security thinking that oh
you know what i've got resting liquidity
here you know i've got a big buyer here
so i gotta buy right in front of it or i
gotta sell right in front of the big
seller
sometimes that works sometimes it
doesn't
okay because orders are constantly
getting pulled bids and offers are going
in they're coming out now you look at
a book map or a heat map
and you see big orders of resting
liquidity well you know
and you're seeing at these other levels
like 50 contracts you know 50 50 50
right if you look at the dome right
you're seeing 26 14 13 and then you know
sometimes you see 180 right that would
be your your big level in the wrestling
liquidity but just because it's 14 13 17
doesn't mean it's not orders iceberg
most orders that are above
10 contracts nowadays are iceberg in the
market that's why when you look at a
footprint chart
right you're seeing the volumes of 100
100 100
you know at each price level right even
though if you look at the dome
currently you don't really see much in
there but people you know
algos are working you know those
execution algos as well you know where
people are hiding their size um
they're all there to hide the size
from other traders you know people don't
you know if you're a big trader and
you got 500 s ps to buy you don't pop in
500 lots right here because you know
that if you do
that this is what's going to happen in
the market
all right mark is just going to run on
you
so you got to hide your size you know if
you're
really interested in getting into this
trade you need to hide your size you're
going to icebreak the order and hope
that it comes down and and fills you
now
sort of the what i want to talk about is
is order flow what we call sequencing
okay because
if you're looking
at the order book right you see in here
right you see size right but size
constantly gets entered and pulled it
gets adjusted it gets modified up
modified down
you know it trades through
people think that automatically that
there's you know a big line in there
that there's big liquidity that's going
to stop the market no
big traders are attracted to big size in
the market because why is because if
you're a big trader and you got a lot to
trade you got a lot to get out
you need that size in there so you know
big size yeah it acts as a magnet
and you know sometimes you're going to
see you know or just like the market is
just sucked down to a level like down
here or sucked back up to a level up
here
but a lot of times you're going to see
the market you're going to see the
levels right the lines drawn out
and the market just eats through that
eats through that eats through that and
when that happens
then you have a strong market when a
market is able to eat through size eat
through more size eat through more size
either to the upside or to the downside
then it's a strong market condition
right you know the market is is often
trending
and like i said you know on a on a
footprint chart right when you see the
volumes that actually trade right you're
seeing
you know 400 contracts straight here 500
here 400 here you know 600 here 600 here
whereas if you're just looking on the
dome you think ah there's there's no
size in there well there there is it's
just hidden
right people are using
execution algos or hiding their size
they're using icebergs
to get their size off that just because
you don't see you know any liquidity in
here doesn't mean there's there's no
liquidity in here if you're looking at
the
dome you just think oh there's only 12
lots here well yeah someone buys the 12
it loads up another 12
right or loads up another 10 another 10
another 10.
right so even though you see it so it's
like 14 here 12 here could actually be
150 contracts here at 76 you know
130 here at 76 and a quarter 200 at 76
and a half but the only thing that's
showing is just 17 12 and 14.
now sequencing okay is again it's when
the market has to eat through more size
and
if you're looking on a footprint chart
this is where you gotta look at the
numbers and it's hard to see okay that's
why
when i talked about my software earlier
this is something that i'll look for in
the market is what we call sequencing
where the market has to eat through
subsequent higher bids on the way down
or subsequent higher volumes when i say
higher i mean more at each level on the
way up or more at each level on the way
down and
having software that highlights that to
you
just
so you can see it at a glance it's going
to give you
an insight into the market that traders
are just looking at a bar chart aren't
going to see people that are looking
at a normal footprint chart
probably aren't going to see
you can see it right here this is
bearish sequencing here this is bearish
sequencing if you know what to look for
you can spot it right
but
it's hard sometimes right because you
got to be on your game and if you're
looking at more than one chart it's good
something you might miss
that's why you know having software that
highlights these little nuances in the
order flow to you is going to give you
an edge
you know here's some nice
bullish sequencing here here here here
on the way up even here
right so you're going to see bullish
sequencing on the way up or bare
sequencing on the way down and you know
just sort of to get back to your foot
your
footprint chart your depth of market
chart
one of the the
ways traders use a book map or a heat
map is knowing where these levels are
right okay well yeah you know i got
resistance up here i got resistance here
got resistance here okay that's fine
it's very visual
like i said a lot of traders hide their
size
but the problem is people traders tend
to get complacent they think well i got
resistance here i got support here i'm
looking for the market to trade through
here but when it starts eating through
size
right if you're sharp enough to notice
that it's eating through
level one
or the first price level 50 contracts
the next contracts there's 100 next
contract next level 150 next level 250
next level 350
because that's how big orders are worked
in the market
right if someone's got 500 to sell they
just don't put it all 500 at one price
iceberg it you know they're gonna put in
um you know 100 at one level
you know maybe 150 another level the
other 250 at a higher level and let the
market come up and sort of
eat its way through that market so
they're going to get a better fill on
the average price
and that's where you're going to see
sequencing occurring and you know that
if there's a big order there that the
market has to eat through or big levels
that the market has to eat through it's
going to give you that edge right if i
know that
someone you know this was an area of
support right here i mean i could see
that
with the point of controls all sort of
lined up right here so i know that there
was probably
more support here as the market's coming
down and it's been
broken up it's been spread out through
this these different
levels so i know that the market is
eating through these levels and if i
know the market is eating through
heavy volume
it's probably a strong move that's going
to happen
and that's the thing right with
something like a depth
map you know a book map
if you know right say you're long right
so you get your long from in here okay
you're you know i don't know what the
price is called this
4120 just you know i'm just making that
up cause 4120 up here at 41.30
you know i got some offers here
but my take profit is up here at uh
you know 4140
okay but if i'm starting to see volume
in here it's got to eat you know that
there's a chance that it might not get
through that volume to go to your
take profit level
right so
if you're in this trade and you you see
these heavy levels these heavy volumes
in here
and your take profit is up here and the
market just sort of comes up and sort of
starts crapping out yeah that's one sign
you can get out
but if you know your take profit is up
here at 41.40
but at 4130
you got some heavy volume to eat through
and it eats through that
you know this market is strong
maybe you don't want to sell it at 4140
anymore you back it up to 45 back it up
to 50.
you know now that it's got through that
resistance area
then you can stay in the trade longer
and if you know
where that resistance is that the market
ate through it like if i know that if
i'm short from you know if i say oh you
know we hit this high you know i got
short up here you know whatever 71
some reason support down here but then i
see that we eat through that support
pretty easily pretty
quick instead of covering it down here
at 65
i could hold it longer
you know i could get out at 60 because i
know i had i had support there and the
market just ate right through it like it
was
you know a an ice cream sandwich
just as if
you know if i'm long from in here at 40
you know whatever this is 40 98 and i
got to take profit up here at uh
you know 4108 but i see that we have to
eat through a lot of size here i mean or
afterwards i see that we ate through a
lot of size subsequent higher offers
all of a sudden my 4108s look very easy
to reach i could back up to 10
higher
right that's how orderful is going to
help you stay into trades longer here's
another example this is gold right the
charts i showed you before are e-minis
here's the market eating right through
some
resistance here in the market right it
just keeps going up
through
higher
levels in here in here as we keep going
up and it's not just with
futures right this is apple stock
there's a five minute apple
chart
all right
mark it went up came off then people you
know every time the market sort of
shoots up we always you know come off a
little bit you want to see if people are
going to start working offers people
thinking that oh we hit a high
now we're going to start selling right
so they're going to
start working in offers in here to sort
of
you know get rid of their supply and
sort of put a cap on the market but if
the market starts eating again right
through that size
you know you want to you know pay
attention to that because now i got
supply coming into the market
but people are you know traders are
happy to to buy it because they're
thinking this market's going higher and
see it just keeps going up up up
now
traders like to use tools like um
rsi to determine if something is
overbought okay and this is a thing that
a trap that a lot of traders fall into
they think that
overbought means expensive or oversold
means
something's cheap all it means is when
the market is overbought just means the
price has gone up a lot
or
if
um you know market is oversold it just
means that the market is going you know
it's been going down down down
and it's going to keep going down
so
does overbought really mean expensive no
it just means there's been an excessive
run of higher highs
and
when you think of price how do you
determine if something is expensive or
cheap well you think in terms of value
right and again you know with the
overbought and over sold indicators like
rsi you know and talks about rsi it's a
relative strength indicator but it's
just relative to the previous bar you
know are we going higher or not
it's not really
taking much else into account but you
know here for example right we're above
overbought we also we're above 70 we're
overbought you gotta get short well then
the market ripped from you know 40 85
all the way up to 41.25 it still had
another
40 points to go
but a market can go overbought over
bought overbought overbought and keep
going overbought
it doesn't mean that it's too expensive
you know that that's sort of the fallacy
that the problem that people have with
using indicators to determine if
something's overbought or oversold
really what you the way you determine
if something is expensive or cheap
is you look at
what the value is of something right i
mean you go to a store i mean now you
know with inflation you know the other
day i was in
walmart
looking to buy eggs right i used to be
able to buy eggs there
and get a box of 60 eggs
i used to pay like under 4 under dollars
it was like 484 for 60 eggs
and now i went there the other day
look at the price for the same box that
i used to buy and i'm not saying you
know this was like last week you know i
used to buy this i used to buy those
eggs there at you know before kovid
and even drink of it
up until about a year ago i mean it did
go up to about six dollars last year now
it's 12
does that mean it's overbought no it's
just you know it's expensive okay the
value of it is going up
now
most traders right they look at
a footprint chart like this and the way
they like to measure value is
sort of by looking at the at the point
of control right the price level in the
bar is with the highest price level with
the highest volume
and that's one way okay
but there's other ways just to see it
right i talked about looking at the
value areas right you could put the
value area
on your chart
and
when you do that
so it's you can start to see where
there's shifts so you know imagine
you're just looking at your plane
footprint chart like this right people's
you know you just came up here made a
new high by a tick immediately came off
okay fine
but when you start adding the value
areas onto your chart
right now it becomes a lot clearer
because i'm going to get into this in in
a in a
few minutes
with value areas there's bullish value
areas and there's bearish value areas
right it's not just finding areas where
value is overlapping there's times where
value areas are bullish
on itself and bearish on itself
right and you imagine you come up here
to this high you see a bearish value
area
the market is telling you
in this bar
the value area went from a bullish
reading to a bearish reading at the high
of the day
and then you can see the value area
gapped down here
and we drop you know quite nicely
here's an example this is just last
night right last night in the e-minis
you can see the value area is
overlapping one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
bars it's overlapped then it gaps up
here so you know you're sort of looking
for this market to start trading higher
but what happens again it starts
overlapping as soon as you see value
areas start overlapping
you know the market has a chance
of just
going sideways right and that's what
you're seeing here now that you're
starting to see the value areas
overlapping you know this market has a
chance of going sideways
again this is last night
this is that
this is that second part right here
um it's coming in right here
now you're starting to see you know it
gapped down but then it overlapped
gapped up
now this is not a gap but it's one of
those what we call like the kiss
valuaria low equals the value very high
gaps down here okay you're starting to
gap down you got the kiss you got your
value very high and value really low
evaluate a high of this bar equaling the
value very low of this bar
it's almost a gap
then you do have a clear gap here
so you know how it's starting to move
down okay it moves down
value area hits you know value where it
hits the low here then it gaps up you
got one gap two gaps now you know this
is gapping back up right market is
starting to move higher
there's no overlap in the value areas
you got one here
but it gaps again here so now you know
the trend is back up again you know this
is something that's going to give you
some insight into the market as to
the direction of it going you know
here's another chart right these markets
look the same right these charts look
the same but actually they're different
but you've seen the activity the same
gap in value area gap in value area what
do you think yeah two gaps in a row well
it's probably going to keep continuing
and it keeps continuing going up
right so that's how you can use value
area
to make
decisions on you know trends that are
starting
that the market could be happening
so
it's going to give you ways to look at
the market on on how to trade it
so the next thing i'll talk about is how
you can use order flow analysis to your
advantage in today's market conditions
now the vix right i i
honestly i took this last night this
reading
and
it was at 26.5 i don't know what it is
uh today i haven't updated this but
honestly 26
you know we're sort of coming into this
area you know this era where 26 you know
vix in the mid-20s is like normal
but it's not right ideally you want to
be below 20. okay i mean i don't think
we've been below 20
at all this year maybe once or something
but you know volatility is there and
you're going to see days like this
this was just this was the 20th right
you remember that big sell-off that we
had then it just boop
reversed closed
almost unchanged right got back up it
was almost unchanged and this is a rally
from 3810
back up to 3 900 a 90-point rally
but the majority of it happened you know
80 70 points happened in the last hour
and that's what happens when you have a
volatile market but when you watch value
where it's forming in relation to where
the market is trading is going to give
you some insights because within value
analysis like i said earlier there's
bearish value there's bullish value and
if there's a way you could highlight
that on your chart that's easy to see
then you know that's going to give you a
big edge
and that's one of the things that we
have programmed into the order flows
trader is being able to see bearish
value we highlight the value area
as
red
or
we
highlight the bullish value area
um you know as as blue
so this is a bearish value area right up
here at the high of the day if it's
bearish what do you think is going to
happen the market's going to sell off
here's bullish value area right here
okay but it just still goes sideways now
the market starts running that bullish
value area right here
another bullish value area right here
here's the e-minis this is a five-minute
chart you know i showed you a 30-second
chart a one-minute chart is a
five-minute chart now you don't have to
keep
ten different charts open you know you
just put it on the chart that you're
using whether it's you know a one minute
chart or it's a tick based chart or
whether it's a volume based chart
again here's another one five minute
chart this is
another high of the day and the market
sells off
see e-mini's another you know market was
just sort of going sideways got your
bearish value area
right as the market breaks to sell off
right i mean this is a move from you
know
the 20s
all the way down below the figure
it's crude oil
right you hit your high of the day
bearish value area market sells off
buns
okay
the ones just open here it was trading
in a tight range we had some bearish
value area
right here in here
hit the low
this is when the cash opens in germany
bullish value area and the market takes
off to new highs
all right so
the thing to keep in mind with trading
right as humans we like to make things
more
complex you know than they really need
to be we like to make things difficult
and
in trading sometimes you know the more
complex the trading methodology is
the more likely you're going to run into
obstacles either you know mental or
in actual market conditions and it's
going to hinder your trading
because you're going to be confused on
whether you should take a trade
or not and oftentimes you're just going
to pass on the trade and sure enough
that was the trade you should have taken
and it was a big would have been a big
winner
so
trading
successfully requires taking calculated
risk making quick decisions and simple
and obvious is going to give you
that advantage but more so than complex
and convoluted because when it starts
getting complex and convoluted you start
to lose sight of what you should be
looking for in the market
order flow in my opinion is the simple
and obvious way right it's you know you
all hear the same kiss right keep it
simple
and that's what order flow helps you to
do so over the last 45 minutes or so
hopefully you'll agree it's been time
well spent that you've learned something
now regrettably i can't cover everything
in a quick training session like today
but i got a special offer so you get
everything you need to know about order
flow and to get started right and i got
a very special deal for you it's the
order flows trader 5.0 software i talked
about a couple of the the tools that are
available on it is you know the the
value areas and seeing where bullish and
bearish value areas are
i talked about order flow sequencing is
a tool that we have on the overflow
straighter five
and what it's like is it's like
taking all the knowledge that i've
gained on trading with order flow over
you know 25 years and put it into a
program
so you can see what the institutional
traders are doing in the market because
at the end of the day it's really what
the big money traders are doing in the
market that's going to
influence as you know what's happening
in the market
so you have to think like an
institutional trader but unless you've
actually worked on institutional trading
desk you're not going to know
now
having order flow software is one thing
right you still need to know how to use
it
and
i don't just they'll sell you the
software and go okay you know go figure
it out on your own i give you a lot of
extra training and education
so that you learn how to trade with
order flow right i mean you could spend
thousands of dollars on software and if
you don't know how to use it what's the
point so i'll give you access
when you get the orthotrader 5 i'll give
you access to my order flow trading
course which i regularly sell for 297 on
my website
also give you access to my
order flow inner circle video series
right there's 56 videos on advanced
order flow tips tricks and analysis onto
the nuances of the market and normally
right the only way to get the inner
circle video series is by purchasing the
order flows trader software it's not
available anywhere else anymore
and before when it was available it cost
a lot more
than what you see here the 497
but the training another 297 and the
overflows trader software is 8.99 that's
already sixteen hundred dollars now
i do realize that
trying to learn how to trade by watching
videos and
reading books
is one way to go about it but it's
difficult right requires discipline and
commitment on your part
and what i found to be very helpful
for traders is live training where you
can ask questions
right it's one thing to send emails back
and forth you know because there are
delays you know
you can send an email to me i might
not see it for
you know a day honestly you know say
mike you know what do you think of this
chart that's why i have each week a live
training session
right where
normally it's tuesday nights it would be
tonight but because of the holiday i i'm
not having it tonight but for the last
three years i've been hosting it
every week
and you know
barring holidays
and it's open for all users of the
software
people that have the software that are
using it successfully you know they come
in and they watch i will talk about
special situations i saw on the market
you know if people have questions about
a particular market on a particular day
you know they can either send me their
chart and i'll pull it up in that in the
session or
i'll refer i'll find it on my charts and
show it and it's an area where you know
even if you're having problem
like
with the software like how do i do this
with that you know
how do i maximize you know the software
that's what these sessions are there for
so you can learn how to become a better
user at the software because you know
the software is very robust and
you know sometimes people don't realize
what they have in front of them and by
watching these sessions you know you can
learn how to use the software
better
now there's archives if you can't attend
you know each
session is recorded honestly if you
can't attend when each week when i send
you the registration link you're just
better off signing up for it that way
you'll automatically be sent the replay
link
but if not there is an archive section
and right now we've got like 167
episodes and again some
gurus out there will charge you extra
for training like this but this is free
i don't charge you a monthly charge for
that now
again you know what i discussed today
with orderful sequencing and value areas
is just a small sample of the forms of
analysis i talk about weekly and what's
available in the inner circle video
series and other trainings i have
available you honestly i think you'll
learn more about
order flow in the weekly sessions than
you thought possible
so to get started all you have to do is
go to orderflows.com slash off five
html you'll
be on this page you just scroll down to
the bottom of the page i put the link
i'll put the link in the chat right now
so you just go to this page and you
scroll down
right that's all you got to do
and when you scroll down it's just going
to take you you know there's some videos
that you can watch
but it's going to take you to this
button down here to get started you can
see it's just a one-time payment of 7.49
you get lifetime access to the overflows
trader
the access to the order flows trading
course
the order flows inner circle video
series weekly live group trainings and a
special bonus
which is my order flow trading
my order flows playbook trading course
again just
click that button 749 takes you to
paypal paypal processes your payment i
don't get your credit card i don't want
it right it's all done through paypal
it's just a one-time payment of
749. so just go to orderflows.com5.html
and again you know for a special bonus
for investors expos i'm going to give
you a copy of my order flows playbook
course it's a it's a nice course there's
about another
10 or 11 trading setups that you can
learn in there as well
so again to get started go to
orderflows.com slash off five dot html
and you can see what you're going to get
right again the order flows trader 5.0
which is normally 8.99 so for 749 not
only you can get the software for a
lower price we're going to get all this
extra stuff right you can get the order
flow trading course
the inner circle video series you're
going to be able to participate in our
live weekly group trainings you're also
going to get access to the order flows
playbook
just for 7.49 now if you stuck around
and you want a copy of my book how to
get it is you go to
orderflows.combook.html
enter your name and email address and
click submit
sometimes people will enter their name
and email and not hit submit
but
hit submit and you'll be taken to the
page i've checked this page it does work
but you have to it's not orderflows.com
book it's orderflows.combook.html
you gotta enter the dot html
so to get started all you gotta do is
just go to orderflows.com5
to get started and that's all you really
need to do um you know i got there's a
couple questions in here
yeah trader i'll get to these here
someone says it's cheaper now to buy the
chickens to lay the eggs but a little
messy if you live in a small apartment
yeah
it's uh then
it's always cheaper to buy the eggs the
chicken
does order flow
tool
does oh wonderful tool if we use it with
data feed
does
well okay you know a question i get is
do i need a special data feed no
you just need your normal level 1 data
feed you do not need level 2 that you
would need in depth of market
like
the dome or something like a
a
depth map or a heat map or a book map
what is the difference on this tool
versus volume profile which shows where
volume is well
volume profile just shows you
where price traded
over
the day i mean most people use a volume
profile for the entire trading day
or you know maybe they might split it up
over the cash session and some people
even split it up over 30 minute periods
um
order flow a footprint chart will look
at volume that's traded on the bid and
offer depending on you know your chart
type if you look at a one minute chart
it's going to show you where volume
traded on the bid in the offer what the
quantities were over that one minute
period right if you use a five minute
same thing if you use a tick based chart
over the amount of ticks or volume based
chart over the amount of volumes
so the another question i get is can i
use it on 4x well it's really best used
on futures because it's a centralized
um what do i call it centralized
data right with forex you get a lot of
different data feeds because many of the
forex brokers out there are basically
white labels from banks you know it
could be from barclays jpmorgan had one
goldman sachs
you know all the different big banks
they white label their their forex front
end to
companies
so
you know it's not centralized but if
you're trading forex there are forex
futures right there's euro currency
british pound japan etc that trade
through the cme which you know a lot of
traders trade it
does it work only with ninjatrader yes
unfortunately um
there are versions
of other footprints that work with
sierra charts and like motive wave but
not my order flow suite
will this work with charts that are set
with a black background yes i personally
you know your chart background is a
personal taste i know ninjatrader's
default is black
i prefer white it's just easier on my
eyes um
the setup that i have is is for a white
background but all you had to do to
change it to a black background is just
change the font colors because obviously
i got a white chart with black numbers
all you have to do is just change the
font for color from
black to white so yes it can be well all
right everybody i've gone for about an
hour um thank you all for attending
um again you know if you're interested
in my book
if you haven't gotten it already just go
to orderflows.combook.html
download it it's an interesting
um book you know hopefully you can find
something useful that you can apply to
your trading and again to get started
with the order flows trader five just go
to orderflows.com5.html
so have a great
rest of your week everybody have a great
the rest of your day as well
and thanks
and bye
you